J'espère que vous êtes prêt, parce qu'ils vont pas tarder...
C'est un fusil ?
T'as jamais vu de fusil ?
Non, parce que avant c'était plutôt moi les flingues
et toi les épées, mais bon...
apparemment tu t'es aussi mise aux flingues.
J'étais pas au courant.
Oh, c'est chaud.
Je vois tout ça en vous.
La peur
La jalousie
La trahison
Il est de notre devoir de débarrasser l'univers de ces tares.
C'est drôle, on m'avait dit que vous étiez des crétins prétentieux.
Mais c'est pas vrai du tout ! ;)
Rocket !
Quoi ? J'avais un truc dans l'oeil !
Groot! Mets ta ceinture !
On doit encore sauver la galaxie ?
Ouaip.
Génial !
On va pouvoir augmenter nos tarifs,
si on devient sauveteur de galaxie à plein temps.
Ouaiii...
Va mourir !  Sale vaisseau !
Salut !
Parfois tu t'aperçois que la chose que t'as passé ta vie à chercher, est là depuis toujours à côté de toi.
T'as raison !
Tout ce que vous savez faire c'est vous crier dessus.
Vous n'êtes pas des amis.
Non. On est une famille.
Mais elle, j'suis pas sûr.
Ça fait des années que je te cherche.
Et vous êtes qui vous ?
Je suis ton père, Peter.
Le destin de l'univers repose sur tes épaules.
Fais ce que tu veux, mais surtout....
N'appuie pas sur ce bouton.
Ça ferait immédiatement exploser la bombe,
et on mourrait tous.
Allez, vas-y. Répète ce que je viens de te dire.
Je z’appelle Groot.
Nooon !
Ça, c'est le bouton qui risque de tous nous tuer.
Recommence.
Je z’appelle Groot.
mmmh.
Oui.
Je z’appelle Groot.
Noooon !
À vous de jouer, bande de nazes !
Ouaiii !
Tu m'énerves sale vaisseau !
Bon, qui a de bande adhésive ?
J'vais en coller sur le bouton de la mort.
Nan, on n'a pas de bande adhésive.
C'est pas vrai. Y'en a pas un qui a de la bande adhésive?
T'as une bombe atomique dans ton sac,
si quelqu'un peut avoir de la bande adhésive,
c'est bien toi !
Il faut que je me tape tout le boulot !
Tu nous fait perdre beaucoup de temps !
Je z’appelle...
Grooooooot !
C'est très très mauvais signe...
Quand je touche quelqu'un,
je ressens tout ce qu'Il ressent.
Toi tu ressens...
de l'amour.
Euh, oui oui, c'est vrai. Je ressens un amour désintéressé pour tout le monde, ou presque.
Non !
Un amour sexuelle.
Mais non. Pas du tout.
Pour elle !
Nooon.
Oh Ah Ah Ah!
Elle vient de dire à tout le monde
le plus secret de tout tes secret !
Euh oui, bon ben ça va, hein.
Arrête d'en faire des caisses, hein s'il te plait.
Elle t'a mis la honte, ma parole !
Ah ah ah !
Oh ah ah!
Allez ! A mon tour !
A moi ! A moi !